concrete inherently is a flawless
airtight material what's important to
know is that with any structure if you
have a small flaw it can cause big
problems I have small or very small take
this a piece of plastic so bendable
right now it's not breaking you can give
it a try right yeah who's been d no
flaws no now if we add a flaw just a
small little cut well that's it that's
it do the same thing give it a try look
at that and that was it that's enough
you can't have any flaws can cause big
problems grant and his colleagues
devised a test to show what might happen
to trolls legs if they had a small flaw
firstly they put a seam in a large
plastic container and then we seal it
then they fill the container with water
and apply some pressure explosive
pressure
everything is in place one very very
slightly flawed water tank system armed
it's live three two one
it went bang Wow let's have a look so
what are we looking for where and why
well you observe that there is a large
gash yes structure it's broken the flaw
that we manufactured we exposed it to a
large force and we see failure so that
small floor that join is compromised the
entire strike that's right and this
could happen as well in a concrete
structure any type of structure really
and that's what we're trying to avoid
judging by that just a small weakness in
a concrete would be lethal for the troll
but grant also wants to show me the
solution simply avoid defects or
weaknesses so round two will the exact
same plastic stand the same pressure if
it doesn't have a seat system armed it's
live three two one
did it sustained damage did it make it
let's go see looks to be intact I think
you're right it survived it it did
survive and this is same conditions same
amount of water same charge examined
today oh yeah the only difference is
that there's no manufacturing scene or a
joint as your recliner and that was our
floor but our floor was where it was
joined together and that's the same of
concrete is it is of this plastic that's
right the same principle there's no flaw
minimizing the chance for damage on a
catastrophic scale floors or seems our
lines of weakness but how did the troll
engineers make a thousand foot high slab
of concrete without a single see the
secret is to build without ever stopping
24-7 rain or shine I wanted to get up
close to another concrete structure
that's been built using the same
technique to see how it's done this time
it's a power station in Britain
unfortunately it means doing something I
hate
I have to travel 600 feet up into the
air in a small steel okay